In our next algorithm, we want to find the largest element in an array list.
Again, let's look at the example of our pictures. We might want to know the
largest one, to know how much vertical space we need on the wall. Or maybe we
want to center them all with respect to the largest one, then we need to know
the largest one first. In this algorithm, we start assuming. That, the first
element, or rather the element at index 0, is the largest one. Then we look at
all other elements, and if an element is larger, by some measure, than the
largest element, then we change our mind, and now say the largest element, is
the one that we've just seen. So in this example, for example, we would start
off by saying, oh, the first one that we've seen, that's the tallest picture.
Then we move onto the next one, and say that one is taller so I'm changing my
mind, and now this one is now the tallest. this one is even a bit taller, so
that one must be the tallest. Now this one here is not as tall so we no longer
change our mind. And the last one that was considered to be the tallest is in
fact, the one. Just like we've done before, I now leave it to you to implement
this code in Java, and this time I want you to actually draw the tallest
picture. Go ahead.